[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan Taz is here
hello tell you tell yes that's me tear
it together tie it together
guys thanks for listening um yeah you
like that yeah sure oh good that's good
I hope you're having a great week and
thanks for choosing this podcast if
you're here for Rachel Lee Cook you came
to the right place and I hope if you
like the interview you'll subscribe and
write a review and follow us on our
handles which are at inside of you pod
on Twitter outside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook yeah I was
yawning and I saved it I think you did
you could you could obviously listen to
us anywhere but uh YouTube if you're
watching um we appreciate it and um
those of you who want to give back to
the podcast like many of you do that
keeps the podcast going it's uh
patreon.com inside of you patreon.com
inside of you become a patron I send
boxes full of merch and notes and we
have zooms and there's just all sorts of
stuff and you get your name shouted out
um it's pretty awesome and uh patrons
have become a big part of my life and a
big part of each other's life so it's
pretty cool also uh the inside of you
online store has a lot of cool stuff
getting new ship Keys you can check them
out Smallville ship Keys autograph by
Lex
and uh lunch boxes and anxiety mugs and
all that stuff so check it out I'm going
to be putting up a discount code in fact
let's just do a discount code now I'll
put it up after Ryan what should the
discount code be
uh Tay it together
how about
Tay
no it's gonna it's too hard do something
easy
um how about
all inside
15 for 15 off all inside
all inside 15. all inside 15 for 15 off
the inside of you online store get it
now it's not gonna be there forever and
uh thanks for listening to talkville uh
Ryan we enjoy doing that yeah it's a lot
of fun today we had some technical
difficulties but Jason will handle it we
did yeah thank you Jason it's thank you
Jason uh but yeah we did one today we
did one today and uh having a lot of
special guests coming up which is really
fun getting to see old friends from that
um so check that out and uh also March
4th and 5th Tom Welling and I will be in
Atlanta Georgia at the creation con with
Jared Padalecki and Jensen Ackles
we're going to do a Smallville nights
event so you have to get tickets to come
see us we read scenes I put the ball cap
on you read scenes with us it's a
freaking blast get your tickets for
Saturday night March 4th and a lot of
other stuff going on what else I mean
I'm going to be doing a lot of cons this
year and um you know I think Guardians
is coming out in the summer and um
guarding this Galaxy 3 and um
just a lot of a lot of groovy stuff you
know a lot of groovy stuff
um trying to do a live podcast and
inside of you one of course and a talk
Ville podcast live we think would be fun
so there's a lot of things in the works
and uh
thanks for all the love is there
anything else oh of course my band
sunspin you gotta go to sunspin.com or
please
um download us we're on Spotify apple
apple music all that stuff listen to the
new album It's called Never is what it
is and I really think you're gonna like
it hopefully you'll support the band and
uh that's about it um Rachel Lee Cook is
the guest I love this girl yeah I mean
she's so
you know what it is when you're talking
to her you really feel like she's
listening and cares
she's just
she just is a good person and I know
this because I know her and I've gotten
to know her a little more and we become
good friends and we hadn't talked for a
long time we were friends but like you
know you lose touch she got married and
had kids and I remained single and alone
and you know but anyway
um she's awesome and she's had a really
great career and she continually works
because people love working with her and
she's got a lot to say and I'm glad she
came in and opened up and let's just uh
let's just get into this
let's get inside
of Rachel Eco it's my point of view
you listening to inside of you
you Michael arose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience didn't we meet in Cabo San
Lucas and you're with Rosario Dawson yep
I was with my friend Chris McDonald yes
yeah you look like something bad
happened and nothing it was just a fun
time yeah I'm just like trying to
remember who else was there Chaka Khan
played on the beach
what it was all downhill from there for
us Michael
where could we go from there I don't I
don't know that was just wonderful that
was a wonderful vacation so [__]
wonderful I vaguely remember
chicken fighting some people in a pool
with with yeah and we won dude yeah my
shoulders
oh my God I forgot about that thank you
we won yeah we did who do we beat some
random couple whatever they were trash
we won
they were such trash
um I'm glad you do remember that though
yeah
I was like she's not gonna remember any
of this and she remembered something
that I didn't remember at all also
there's a few things
I'm glad you finally did this because
you actually listened to the podcast
once right oh my God I'm a fan really
yeah who'd you listen to I listened to
Zach Levi's oh yeah it was that I was so
like oh my God I sound like an old lady
again I was so like proud of you guys
for just like being dudes talking about
feelings and I was just so here for it
like I was just I was riveted like thank
you for that thank you for being as open
and it's
yeah are you not used to guys opening up
like just saying hey here's who I am
no
you haven't used well
here's the funny thing about like I just
think about being a woman just walking
around in the world is that you don't
know how different convert male
conversations are when when you're not
there
like you just you don't know what
ingredient you add to to Any Given
scenario right you know what I mean like
and you'll never know it's like
schroederer's cat you're like you can't
no it's a box like whatever so so yeah
it just it but it felt like I I don't
know it was just it was genuine I really
appreciated it thank you I tried I TR we
try to make them genuine I try to have
real conversations I don't have like
actor actor sometimes you jump in that
inadvertently tell moments but yeah two
inside baseball too sorry Harrison Ford
how do you feel about all my shotskis is
that what you call them yeah yeah how do
you feel all about all that
I feel great about it do you do you keep
anything from your movies or anything
from your [__] TV shows or I uh I
started purging the paper of it all do
you keep your scripts uh I have some
scripts I haven't kept all of them but
like I kept my uh you know like
Guardians of Galaxy 2 script and I I
have like an urban legend script
somewhere do you keep like the the no
but like with all the the collated pages
like all the colors sometimes I think I
do have a few of those do you well see I
feel like those are the ones to keep
like the one like the all-white draft
like no that got recycled along right
right yeah did you keep like she's all
that or the babysitters club one of
those like original babysitters club yes
with notes on it like your markings
I kept conspicuously few notes and if
you watch the movie you will understand
that that is totally consistent with my
performance what do you mean your
performance is great in that
what no like you've seen a babysitter's
Club oh I haven't seen that one yeah
exactly it's it's not a good movie thank
you Ryan knows Ryan have you seen it I
don't think so it's from 90s
how old are you man I'm 34. okay you had
to be there
you've been doing this a long freaking
time
I mean indeed you too don't don't leave
me alone the difference is I as immature
as I can be
I you know I it was a progression
it was incremental it was a high school
play and then an unsure and insecurity
and then a college play and then get
more confidence and then moving to New
York and then doing plays and then some
voice over and that's the way it should
be I gradually got
why do you hate Harrison Ford yeah I
know I keep hitting his rate as a lost
dog I'd never do that maybe you just
made me nervous well the first thing
that happened is she walked in and I
just thought oh my God you smell really
good I wasn't hitting on her or anything
but mine goes
if you're not I don't know what to do
with this just be careful of your
figurines be careful of it
um you're talking about the place yeah
and then so it gradually happened for me
you earned your stripes what I earned
yeah I guess I earned it I mean some
people it happens later but my I didn't
have overnight success like my co-star
and Smallville Tom he pretty much had
overnight success he went from Oblivion
to oblivious to Superstar you know what
I mean yeah you
started acting when you were like seven
yeah yeah kind of yeah now you can't say
that I can't imagine as a little girl
you're like I want to act at seven or
did your mom yeah yeah how did that no I
didn't literally this is um
well let me tell you this because you're
my friend so so I think what happened
was that you know how like all your
parents friends are like
he's a he's a horrible but I was like I
really took that to heart I was like we
need to apparently you guys the people
have spoken like we need to get this out
there we need to get this thing out I am
wonderful apparently do you remember
feeling so wonderful as a little girl
like I am cute everybody thinks I'm just
so cute no I just I I think that I was
just like get you know how
every I feel like every kid was like a
good upbringing is like you know what
maybe my parents are right maybe I can
be whatever I want to be like they gave
me that sort of
confidence so even despite being a super
shy child I was just like what if I like
uh one of the kids who was in my my
grade did like print work because my
parents love to like take out the Sunday
paper and like distribute sections to
everybody and I was just like my
favorite because I'm an intellectual
Ryan I don't know if you know this but I
like the target ads
I like retail I'm a [__] you mean
Target of course yeah so but I was just
like huh I mean those kids got there
somehow they somebody's got to sell
these pajamas
that's like
right like let's do this and so this was
your idea this is my idea it was my
bonehead idea and there's a lot of uh
there are a lot of Fortune 500 companies
that do like advertising that out of
Minnesota so yeah yeah that's
Minneapolis exactly and I'm from right
in the city is that because it's more of
the real heart of America the Midwest in
a sense that they want the the the kids
that look like
no my guess is that it's cheaper to have
factories there and then this way
headquarters are there and then that's
my guess is like why the rest of
everything satellites out from that
point right but I don't know because I
left high school early so I don't know a
lot I didn't finish High School there's
so much I don't know like not to brag
but I don't know a lot of things you
seem pretty smart I mean I went to high
school in college and you never know it
I feel like you know stuff I I don't
know I remember you know I I still have
nightmares of being in high school or in
college and there's a test I just had a
dream the other night they hand out a
quiz and I knew nothing and I was just
like
oh my gosh I when did we go over this so
you never flipped to like the not
knowing your lines nightmare because
like that I feel like it oh that
happened still do you still have that
yes
do you still dream about that yeah yeah
like not not often thank God but like do
you know your Line's usually pretty good
pretty good pretty well yeah oh yeah
have you ever not known them and really
been in trouble
I got in trouble twice in my career I've
gotten in trouble embarrassing
um
one yeah the second time I was
embarrassed it was because
like every bad you know like bad crash
and blames or tools etc etc but it was
an incredibly
redundant speech that used the same
language
uh in four different paragraphs in four
different ways with different words and
so it involved like
doing callbacks to things that happen in
the other paragraph but it wasn't it the
the writing made so little sense it
wasn't good writing that's the key I
would love to totally blame the writing
but if you have any warning whatsoever
and like it it read okay like it made
sense in my mind but I got there on the
day and the collective
um just exhaustion from the shoot
coupled with the fact that it was just
really [__] confusing dialogue yeah I
went up like a lot and I ended up just
being like guys we're gonna piece it
together and I I you said that yeah I
was like I hate that moment for me and
it taught me a lot about like you know
what if I know that my brain's not going
to be able to do this on the day then oh
my God fix it fix it beforehand because
like it was just very embarrassing
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you and who couldn't use a few
better coping skills to be able to
handle all of life's curveballs look if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
inside of you is brought to you by neuro
hacker qualia mind and I'll tell you
something I don't take a lot of pills
but this is something I need and it
works and I take it I've given you some
I I need a sharp mind whatever will make
me feel sharper give me willpower and
productivity
um and I could do get things done qualia
really helps me and I take it every day
and I believe in it I believe in it I've
been taking it for months now and I've
said this before but I I didn't know
that they were a sponsor I was taking
this stuff like I thought I had ordered
it
and then I realized oh you're a sponsor
and I've been taking it and it works
it's uh it's really cool
um
I mean good memory is so important
especially as I get older I'm 50 and I
you forget things and if there's
anything out there that helps me
remember or um you know works for me I'm
going to get and uh our sponsor neuro
hacker combines 28 Ryan 28 of some of
the most research-backed nootropic
ingredients on earth into the ultimate
brain fuel formula qualia mind and it's
been changing people's lives for years
now if you deal with brain fog like me
and Ryan
memory lapses sluggish thinking try
neuro hackers qualia mind it's an all
vegan formula with potent bioavailable
ingredients this company is a hundred
percent transparent no proprietary
Blends you know my mental performance
it's all about how you feel and if
something works for you and it works for
me and I I strongly recommend this the
formula is non-GMO vegan gluten free the
ingredients are meant to complement one
another factoring in each ingredient's
effect on mental Clarity it's also
backed listen to this a hundred day
money back guarantee so you have almost
three months to try neuro hackers
quality of mind at no Financial Risk and
decide for yourself I think you know
don't you think Ryan
that when a product says Hey a hundred
day money back guarantee it's saying
this works
you're not going to send it back because
you're going to feel sharper that is
what they're saying I just I don't know
how you don't try something like that
it's the other companies that don't give
you that you got to be wary of
um I really love this product I'm taking
it like I said every day and see what
one of the best brain fuel formulas on
Earth can do for your mindset go to
neurohacker.com IOU for a hundred
dollars off that's only thirty nine
dollars a bottle as a listener of inside
of you use the code IOU at checkout for
an extra 15 off your first purchase
that's neurohacker.com IOU to try neuro
hackers qualia mind with code IOU to
experience life-changing performance
these statements have not been evaluated
by the Food and Drug Administration
these products and statements are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease
I was just talking to my friend I think
I've told you this but I'm like you know
I'm 50 now I just turned 50. happy
birthday July 11th
does you have a party I think I'm gonna
have one next year oh okay I think I'm
gonna do it next year you know but I was
thinking you know I know I hear Robert
Downey Jr and other actors do it but
they do this earwick
yeah yeah I mean wouldn't that be a
treat well that the two times that I've
like gone up on stuff in my life the
first time was because I was working
with a much much older actor and he had
one he had one so the lines came out a
little different and very delayed and so
it was like there was no flow to any of
it and so I was just like I'm not in a
in a scene I'm doing a scene by myself
and so he was getting the lines so if
you don't know what an earwig is I've
talked about it once before I think
you know what it is no yeah I can't
remember who you talked about it with
but it's been like a year since you
brought it up yeah which is impressive
actually but it is I usually bring
things up but like for instance if
Ryan's whispering in a microphone that's
going to my ear for instance Ryan start
talking I'll talk to Rachel yeah hey hey
cool uh
oh hey Rachel hey Rachel how's it going
um welcome to my Channel
with all my toys all my toys horror
posters my horror posters I don't I
don't know if this team's gonna make the
cut but you know what I mean that's sort
of like that yeah but he was going very
slowly yes exactly he wasn't on his
queue no and you can't also have someone
in your head sort of anticipated like
they they can't dictate your performance
that's also unfair so it's like that's
that's scary you know what I mean like
were you embarrassed
um with that with that instance
I was I was more embarrassed for for him
because I I was sort of in a position on
that one where I was like oh dear I
might have to do the scene basically by
myself
and I I was like when I say I went up
like I didn't go up that bad like it was
not that bad but he was
just in
a different scene or maybe just entire
did it work when they cut it together
yeah if I do say so it does work it did
totally it we figured it out eventually
honestly
but yeah so could we tell some stories
where I don't look like a bad actor can
we do that I mean look I can tell you
stories of me going off a lot I remember
there was I was flying home one time uh
before flying back and forth to
Vancouver and they added a scene in this
movie and I looked at it on the on the
you know on the page I looked down on
the plane excuse me and I and I landed
and I went to set and I kind of I just
didn't have it I just didn't have it but
like on the plane are you like I'll
figure it out
like I thought yeah I just thought I'd
figure it out and it was they wanted a
Warner
and I I they could have made 18 takes
to the point where people were like God
he was so great in the movie and what
happened
oh my God people are staring at me
that's that's scary because you start to
get like you know like you get in your
own head and then it's like you know you
get warm you're flushed you know you're
like oh my God I'm bombing I'm bombing I
don't want to be here I never want to
act again God getting me out of this
I'll go to Italy I'll live somewhere
else not right have you done that it's
not fair to you you know what I mean
like you didn't know it was gonna be a
one or you would have looked at it very
differently if you notice Gonna Be A
Winner I guess I would have yeah I guess
I would have but you seem professional
I've never heard one bad thing about you
in your work I never heard she's hard to
work with what a be it bitty
you ever hear that term bitty she's a
bitty you're bringing it back just I'm
bringing it from you
um so as a kid you looked at a Target uh
magazine uh a magazine Target kids
wearing clothes from Target is that
right yeah and you said I got to do this
if they're doing it I'm cute I'm
adorable according to my neighbors I
could do this and your parents said okay
and they they went to an agent there in
Minneapolis and the next thing you know
then yeah the next thing I know I'm like
you know taking some top shelf photos at
a JCPenney and do you still have those
photos or your mom have those photos
from when you first took pictures yes I
have a very rough bull haircut because
that's just what we did back then did
you have a bowl cut like what's a bowl
cut never you didn't you would know
trust me what is it you would know it
looks like a bowl on your head thank you
Ryan a bowl a bowl
bowl was that your Minnesota coming out
maybe maybe you betcha have you ever had
to do a Minnesota accent uh you just in
my whole life a little bit a little bit
wouldn't you love to do Fargo do you
ever audition for the series no
see what a great voice that's a great
accent you do accents really well don't
you I
okay
what I think is like crazy we're gonna
we're gonna tangent a little bit and
this is like something nice we'll go
back to Target
um we always do we always go back to
target folks no but what I think is so
crazy about casting that actors casting
Minnesota right now
no is that like
we we think that if we're just so
transcendently good that we should be
able to book anything and that's just
garbage
not true because you can just cast the
actual person and then it's like calm
down like you're yeah that's just acting
that's true there's only a couple people
that can actually just like get
something whether or not they're the
best casting for the role like I think
like Kate Winslet and mayor from East
Town is a perfect example because when
you cast her even if she auditioned
you'd be like no we can cast this actual
woman she exists she is there she's
wonderful she can probably only play
that role but she is from that region
and she will get an Emmy and maybe never
work again but like people just
producers everybody they just want that
person these days it's true and we just
blame ourselves and then it's just like
bad are you hard on yourself if you
don't get something
not since really learning that but
before that yeah were you were you
spoiled sort of growing up in a sense
that you were cute you were fun you're
starting to get these Target pictures
and it was moving on you were the kid
now you're probably the kid out of
Minneapolis that was getting all the
bookings a lot of the bookings were
coming from you is that is that probably
true well I I really feel like
entertainment if you stick in it it's
like a it's like a pain now or pay later
kind of situation and I was definitely
lucky up front like I apparently decided
with the universe to like take all my
lucky chips early and that's probably
good because it like gave me enough like
momentum and I I guess uh a reserve of
finances to just keep going and somehow
still believe in myself yeah but other
than that
um yeah it was definitely it was
definitely hard so yeah I'm very good at
being hard on myself are you oh my god
Ryan don't answer that yes
like horrifically I'm very very hard on
myself very very hard but like
you you know that you're a smart person
you know that you're a funny person you
know that you're an engaging person like
what are you hurting yourself about
I was hoping for handsome or charming
we're gonna get there we're gonna get
there eventually we gotta we gotta keep
your head no my head's in the room no
I'm just kidding I'm kidding but you
know you hear these stories obviously of
these Child Actors and they just [__] go
to hell they just become alcoholics and
drug addicts and rightfully so they
don't have any sort of understanding
about the real world or in this like
bubble and all of a sudden they're just
pushed you know the Biebers of the world
and the uh what's his name I just read
his uh just a geek Will Wheaton Will
Wheaton talks about like he never even
wanted to do it but his mom sort of made
him do it and you know he had his
falling out and sort of like you know
now he doesn't talk to his parents at
all cut them off completely which is the
hardest thing he's ever had to do and he
was on the podcast talked about that and
um
when did you hit that spot did you ever
hit that spot or were you always like
hey I'm lucky I I had a good head on my
shoulders I didn't Veer too much that
way
well I just I think that I just never
like that successful what do you mean no
like I feel like things went pretty good
but it was never like you never were
Superstar is what you're saying I feel
like there was just never this like line
of people like waiting to like high-five
me and tell me I'd made it like by the
time I sort of had any awareness that
like things were going pretty good I was
already that that was already
in a way in the rear view like that the
that ship had already kind of sailed and
I felt like I was going into catch-up
mode really yeah and you're saying like
she's all that when that whole thing
yeah like when when you're it was very
strange when people are like oh my gosh
you're in a movie that's in the theater
so it's the number one this weekend
exactly and it made all this money and
people are excited because it made money
you just it it feels like an accident
and then you're kind of like I I mean it
took me probably
I don't know two three years to be like
oh that was kind of neat and then I
didn't book anything that was totally
awesome until Josie and the Pussycats
after that because I was just like
trying to be cool and live in indyville
and do like fun Indie movies and like
I don't know have that kind of like
so-called credibility because that scene
was so vibrant at the time you remember
you were there oh yeah so um so yeah by
that point
and then I made Josie which didn't make
any box office money and then when
people think that you don't make dollars
and cents you're in trouble
isn't that something that becomes a big
cult movie and people tons of fans come
out of the word work later yeah 20 quick
years later here we are I mean it's a it
is before that oh totally totally but
it's uh but it's scary to be attached to
a dollar value you know what I mean it's
like it worked for me I've never been
attached to a dollar value no but like
but you are in the sense that like you
can like those movies that your agent
you know calls you about that are like
hey Michael we got an offer it's XYZ you
know 100K for you to go to Bulgaria
Saskatchewan yeah or Saskatchewan for
for
um they can shoot you out no no they can
shoot you out in two weeks and then
there's some people who you have never
heard of but who have a lot of credits
in Croatia and the rest of the movie and
you're just like oh okay like this is
what this movie is worth overseas like
that's like that's what those those
paychecks and those movies so wow after
you did She's All That which became this
you know big hit you never really felt
the success for a long period of time
I'm like oh my God I'm a star I'm a
movie star I did you ever feel that
moment of like I made it because you
said before you know
like it wasn't very long after that you
were looking in the rearview mirror it
felt like attention but I was never
comfortable with like attention
attention you never liked it no no it's
it's weird because like I I can't like
public speaking I mean you're like no I
can't I've never this I don't like
admitting this to actors is something
I'm self-conscious about but like I've
never done theater
like ever and I know but I feel I feel
like a faker
why because I just you're supposed to do
it no you're supposed to like Stomp the
boards whatever let me tell you
something I I hate that too because like
I come from the theater and I am an
actor
if you're natural if you're good if you
love what you do
don't be sorry for anything just because
you didn't that wasn't your background
this is how this was your path that's
not everybody's path thank you it
doesn't mean you're not good enough or
oh she's not trained you made it because
of you
and I'm trying to say that to myself too
I tell that to myself all the time like
I was I grew up in a small town I wasn't
to amount to [__] no one knew me I
wasn't yeah I was going to work at a
grocery store I was going to work at
Sunoco gas station I was gonna make five
dollars an hour okay so this is going to
be my life like an imposter syndrome
situation of course I have that I I just
felt like and if nobody's believing in
you and except maybe that one along the
way or two those are the ones that may
get you the confidence enough to keep
going but you had to but ultimate and
you
you had to do it right you could have
bowed out early you could have said not
not for me it's too hard too much
rejection I don't want to do it but not
only did you stay with it you stayed
with it
yeah so well it's kind of like I mean I
don't know I think we've all heard that
Kevin Hart interview where he's like
well no like when he's like I realized
when I was failing Community College
that I had to make comedy work like it's
kind of like the same
kind of the same thing I was like oh
dear I'm not good at anything you really
felt like I'm not gonna do anything else
this is the only thing I'm good at yeah
like I I did fine in school but like
nothing else would like popped out at me
you know what I mean like were you like
oh maybe I'll be a doctor or like that
Suncoast so yeah somebody was gonna sell
the gas Michael somebody has to sell the
gas I thought that's what I do I thought
I'd make a living
and I'd have all my friends and you know
drink a little bit and
I thought that's where I'd end up I
didn't think I was going to get out and
everything just sort of it was almost I
believe this whether you believe it or
not Ryan you probably don't you're
cynical
what no you're not I could tell you
haven't said very much but I could feel
it I'm a flying on the wall I got my
notes you spelled Rachel right
r-a-c-h-a-e-o I did cute I didn't
I forgive you you didn't even have to
admit that it's so transparent of you
thank you Michael you're welcome I know
it's very honest
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection what was I saying you
were talking about how you didn't think
you were going to get out and I had a
question for you about that which is
like but wasn't like everybody I feel
like has got that one person in their
Town who there's like that lore around
that person who got out or who wrote a
book or who became an actor or a singer
like that just that one person from your
town like are you that person who was it
if it wasn't you
I would just say this
I will say that I feel like the hand of
fate
true true story I believe in fate
the hand of fate
took me in that direction just grab me
by the [__] shirt and took me I mean
everything if you look at my life
everything happened by someone
almost forcing me to do something you
know it's not force but leading me that
way because maybe they believed in me
like for instance I was taking an acting
class in high school you had to sign
yourself up for that though but I was
just taking it because it was easy just
to goof around I didn't think I was
going to become an actor not easy for
everybody no but they would rather be
like I guess I'll try and be on the
tennis team or something yeah well they
were like oh today we're gonna learn how
to mime and I go the first thing that
came to me was I'm gonna I'm gonna mime
a guy having to go to the bathroom to
take a [__] and he's rushing to the
bathroom I remember in drama class he's
pretty good at that I could see it so
I'm miming the toilet paper I'm like oh
my God and I'm doing this as a mime and
the whole class is laughing this is
where my mind goes just make everybody
laugh I'm hiding behind a facade because
I didn't I I didn't like me I was so
yeah what's your persona at this stage
that you do that where had you been like
more reserved like it was just weird and
insecure and all over the
no I just kind of didn't fit in anywhere
and I remember going into my senior year
I signed up for it was called Advanced
drama but it was the same drama class it
was just called Advanced because you
were a senior but you're with all the
freshmans right freshmen freshmen's
freshmen I'm with it freshman Brian yeah
freshman thank you and uh so Mrs Peter
Noster
said you can't take Advanced drama
unless you're gonna audition for a play
and I go
and I'm telling you I was gonna say no
no way I can't audition for play in
front of these people and perform yeah
because like it doesn't seem like you're
just playing or doing a scene where you
can just relate to something no it
sounds horrible like if you're coming
completely from the outside like I have
to learn all these I have to commit this
stuff to memories yeah what that's in
that seems almost impossible that's what
happened and I finally said
okay there's this one part that's just
goofy and I'll just be that guy and I'll
I won't get it anyway
and I auditioned and I got if I didn't
audition for that play we would not be
talking right now I'd be watching you
going oh my God
that movie oh my God I wish I could be
with her man she's smoking
um
right now tell me more about the
bathroom stories no no we're not going
back to the the miming of the bathroom I
know but so when I performed
I I was nervous as [__] and I won't get
into that but I remember the Applause
I have the videotape I have the tape
that someone sent me of everybody coming
up and going out and I was not a lead
character and I came out and the
applause was booming and talk about ego
boost and confident boost I was like
they like me they really like me yeah
and then the next day at school I tell
us all the time popular kid walks by me
goes you were really funny last night
and walked away and I go okay not being
me is the way to go and that got me
going that got me going I wouldn't have
gone anywhere
and from there it was little
moments those same moments of the
teacher going do you really want to be
here do you really want to be an actor
and just like
a lot of luck a lot of luck and a lot of
work but you had to say yes at every
turn and then you have to true and then
you gotta work like you cannot trip
stumble fall into a career yeah not one
that lasts anyway I don't think I mean I
might have been a sports announcer I
might have been uh like there's a line
drive a right field base hit a base hit
by Jimmy crawls now up his Wally backman
batting 274. I'm so jealous you're also
I want to do that
um but like stuff like that I you know
that would be fun but who makes it as a
sports announcer not only a lot of
people not a lot not become famous and
make a lot of money most work like you
know AAA baseball making about 30 grand
a year to announce baseball games and
you know it's it's not an easy thing you
got to be uh what's the guy's name who
everybody
all Michaels
good one keep going the one that a lot
of people Joe Buck Joe Buck you know
people don't like people like I I think
he's great but to get to that level is
just that's not easy but let me ask you
this when you're doing this all this
acting stuff and you're climbing up the
ranks and you're doing your this is your
brain this is your brain on drugs that
was you wasn't it that was you no I'm
just the voice oh the voice the voice
see I wouldn't be the on camera but
you know and you're coming up and you're
doing all this acting were there any
were you ever do you remember being
nervous or I can't do it or anxious or
just were you just confident because you
didn't know better
um
funny just side story about that actual
ad I remember like auditioning like is
very scary to me like like all of us
because we're human beings but that
audition was actually not scary to me
because I was like there's no way I'm
getting this because in the waiting room
there's just literally like 16 models
there were like five ten like beautiful
wafey Calvin Klein types I was like are
you [__] serious like am I in the
wrong room and so I was like this isn't
gonna happen so I I wasn't actually
scared
because you said what do I have to lose
am I gonna get it yeah that is always
the key interesting if you don't give a
[__] but you I mean you'd like it well
it's also possible that they're just
actual models who've never acted before
true but when you have that confidence
where you're like going in there and you
don't care yeah and those nerves that
hinder you from being your best yeah
don't come out
and you could let it all out
that's a rare thing that's so true how
often does that happen to you very
little what about you
it doesn't happen a lot but what I have
those days where I'm like I belong here
and I have those days where I'm like I
don't belong there you know what I mean
I do I do if I like
if if the room is warm and if people are
like really welcoming and the material
is good like a lot is possible have you
had bad auditions no I mean like where
um you really are embarrassed
yeah yeah I remember
um
what happened
you gotta tell us
you gotta tell a story
wiggle I thought I thought that the
scene ended when you know like I'm still
crying I didn't know if she was actually
crying or laughing glad that the scene
ended when you know both the characters
stopped talking but it turns they go
energy gets shot I was like excuse me
I bet she gets shot and you didn't know
that you didn't read the side so I did I
said thing I was gonna have to do it
yeah it looks such an idiot I was like
just like you just did a little thing
like that no like I committed to it but
like after talking about it
I feel like I hit the wall a little bit
with my shoulder
and I just remember thinking my brain my
actual real-time thought was I just wish
they weren't filming this because then
only three of us would know this
happened we would be down to three
people are you laughing about this
during the moment or are you just so
embarrassed afterwards
after like now it's hilarious because I
was like 20 years ago did you get the
part no I did not get the part
oh my God I think I've had those what
happened to you well I had a moment with
um
uh the guy who directed Beavis and
Butthead my my judge
obviously a lot of actors have said oh
my God I love Beavis I love Mike Jones
he's a genius
and I went in for this audition and I go
he likes weird he likes off the you know
just out there okay and I came in I wore
a wig I think because because you were
like keeping it tight at the time I
wasn't Lex Luthor then okay
but I wore this wig
and this
checkered shirt
and a gold chain
and I had a little toy
a little ceramic Golden Retriever
dogs I have a lot of questions I don't
know and I went up
and I just put the golden retriever on
the desk
and then I angled it to him to look at
him and he's like okay
and then I just started doing the scene
and it was weird and I took these really
strange beads and I was kind of doing
all the little accent
man and
something really out there and I thought
man he's gonna go and he goes okay thank
you very much thanks thanks so much
thanks and then you just gotta pick up
the golden retriever and then I picked
the golden retriever
then I walked out and I go
I don't know I I might have done
something really well there I don't I
don't know I don't maybe he's just
because you my manager called me and
said what did you do in there you're
welcome did I get it and I go it goes
dude Mike Church says he's never been
more freaked out in an audition
than the moment when you walked in and
gave that reading that's pretty cool
it wasn't good
it was not good I was not the part and
Mike was like yeah I remember you know
what that's on him for not giving you
any direction and he could have been
like hey I so appreciate you putting so
much thought into this bring the dog
thank you for the dog thank you for your
headpiece like thank you for everything
that's happening here but
we asked you in for a reason and can we
just like why don't you just like go
like take 10 different directions we're
gonna just we're gonna work this out
we're gonna
just we're gonna something else I
freaked him out by the way I have that
golden retriever still
like can you keep things that you have
bad memories attached to like that oh
yeah not bad because this is my family I
feel we're gonna get into it
um no but like
but yeah like the um
but the big win for you I think in that
story is that you weren't like oh I did
that and then I kind of fumbled this
beat and I meant to do it like that like
you did everything that you wanted I
wanted to do I see that as well I did
everything I wanted to do yeah that's it
is it is a win when I just didn't care
and it was one of those moments and I
was like but I was just completely wrong
I was not that was the opposite of what
he wanted wow it's okay
it's okay it's okay that that happened
let me ask you this are you
someone that you do you get anxiety have
you ever have you done what anxiety is
I've heard of it people are talking
about it a lot because I mean it's uh
it's something that a lot of people go
through Ryan to get every guest probably
has a little bit of anxiety but some
people deal with it
you know heavier yeah no no no
definitely I um
I definitely when I was younger and
apparently more ambitious I dealt with a
lot of like just perfectionism not that
it was ever not that perfect was ever
like really on the table but I think
that I felt like I I had so much behind
me I was like you have some success you
have a good uh family you have friends
like
the word potential I feel like has just
haunted me my whole life I I hate that
word I hate the idea that if you just
try to an 11 that you should be able to
like why weren't like why weren't we in
the Olympics Michael I don't know like I
I don't like that so
anxiety to me came from like
sir like like circular thought about
like did you do everything you could
what did you do wrong could you have
done different yeah and your mind like
and I didn't really realize this is
exactly what it was like your mind is
this like it's like a railroad you had
like a railroad train set that like
um just loves to run in certain Loops it
becomes like muscle memory to just have
these thoughts that just sort of run in
a pattern right and yeah and and I took
Zoloft to like break that pattern and it
was a total game changer for me because
almost instantly like the that part of
the track was gone and it that whole way
of thinking left me really yeah so that
Perfection that Loop perfectionism the
loop of that same your mind doing the
same things you're saying that you
started an antidepressant or
anti-anxiety Zoloft that's worked for
you but other people yeah you know other
people this is not an advertisement this
doesn't mean it works for you time ago
yeah because I yeah you know I do
something else but you know um
that is just it that was the key yeah it
caused a it was a complete system
interrupt that changed everything for me
how long did it take before it kicked in
I noticed a difference in the way I felt
after I mean this was a long time ago
now but if I had to gas about four
months because everything's habitual
right like even if your brain's doing
something different it takes a while for
your body to process that and and
everything so yeah I guess about that
now is this something you still use or
you're like you just got out of it and
now that Luke doesn't come back because
of new habits what I think is super cool
about it again this is not a this
once the disrupt happens
it would take effort to bring it back
you know what I mean to to run in those
circles again and so when I went off it
because I knew I was gonna like start
trying to have a kid and stuff
um I never really felt the urge to go
back to it really yeah but yours is
yours is working for you I mean clearly
you're doing great oh yeah I'm on it I'm
nailing it Ryan
doing great kid thanks man thank you
um
I always pictured you as someone who I
mean you may laugh you probably laugh at
me when I say this but someone who just
whoever already what I'm scared no but
just I just always looked at you as
somebody who just is so you're sort of
stoic in a lot of ways you don't let
things get to you or if you do you don't
let people know
like you kind of play it off you kind of
like there's a there's a thing about you
where you're like you're not going to
wear your emotions on your on your
sleeves your arms yeah yeah your arm
sleeves as opposed to those other
sleeves like those leg sleeves yeah
um yeah I'm I'm definitely like uh
like a yeah if if something gets to me
like I will wait until I am like out of
the audition with the failed audition to
like go to my car to cry about it for
sure
are you uh are you an arguer can you
argue with the best of them or you're
like nah I don't like loud I don't like
you're yelling I don't like yelling I
hate I hate I hate loud I hate arguing
which is directly conflicting it's
always at loggerheads with my deep
desire to be right because I love being
right yeah who doesn't uh but no but
like I'm not an arguer but one one thing
about me that I both take pride in and
that is kind of [__] up is that if if
I say something mean to you I meant it
wow like I don't say things I don't mean
you can't be like oh my god did you say
things mean though can you have you ever
said something where you're like I meant
it but I shouldn't have said it no I
meant it have you ever said
I hate you
no what's the worst thing you said to
somebody and meant it
I want you out of my
life what what about you like I'm
literally having to think
I've said things by accident like have
you ever heard of this okay I'm gonna
sound a little woo-woo right now no but
there's this like
okay there's this idea that you can have
thoughts that aren't yours right it's
kind of like a ghost but it's like a
little thought in your mind sometimes
things come out that you're just like
one time I repeated something that
somebody that a friend of mine had said
as a joke it was like kind of a mean
joke but then I repeated it and I was
like I'm not a mean joke person and I
felt really bad about it
um but yeah because that wasn't
something you would say yeah no it was
kind of like yeah it was like it passed
from that friend of mine into my brain
like a ghost and it just came out of my
mouth which is weird because I didn't
even really mean it but why what's the
meanest thing you've said the meanest
thing I've said is
I don't know I feel bad about it but I
said to my mom
I said to her
you know
I love you Mom I do I love you uh-oh I
love you buckle up
but I don't like you
oh I don't like you at all
I'm sure I would never hang out with you
if you weren't my mom and you were my
age I would never hang out with you I
don't like you she I mean I'm a parent
so please take this in the right way she
felt the same way about you
she's like I love you don't like you
right now there was a and I no and I
mean like I love my kids but they're
tough hags sometimes they're small it's
fine like it's not a big deal
well you know there was a wrestler and
he used to say Hulk Hogan his name is
brother love you say Hulk Hogan
I love you
but that don't mean
I like you and it was like his name was
brother love do you like being a mom oh
my God yes it has it changed your life
yeah it's the it's the only game changer
it's the the only actual game changer
what has changed what is it that changes
when you have a child for you
it's weird because you're just like well
guess I could never die great like I
gotta [__] live forever now yeah yeah
yeah like
um
no it's just I I think that the reason
that I was just like yeah I want to be a
parent is
first of all I was just like I I don't
have fomo about not doing that which is
a dumb reason to do something that ended
up being a great decision but I was just
like people seem pretty into this
parenthood thing gonna I should find out
what that's about and then you know and
then you do it and it's just like I I
was just so ready to not for it to not
be the me show anymore like I just was I
was sick of my own [__]
like we've done too many seasons of this
like just cut it and now I am canceled
and they are on forever and maybe
someday I will exist again
that is perfect oh what you just said
made more sense to me than anything you
said
thank you I mean yes and why I'm saying
I remember
my grandfather
and
he said he didn't get along with my
mother everybody knew he didn't like her
and she my dad resented him for not you
know you know accepting his wife
which is understandable my dad is
understandable my dad was angry and my
mom was upset
and I love my grandfather I thought he's
the best thing in the world and he
and he believed in me in unconditional
love and talked to me actually had
conversations just sat there and talked
with my grandfather and I asked him once
you know why he
didn't really like my mom
and he said you know Mikey it's um
I would try I would you know you'd come
to visit and I would I would say you're
gonna be good this time you're gonna
just you're gonna sit there you're gonna
engage you're gonna
and it wasn't 15 minutes of her talking
I
had to get out of there I had to take
you kids to go play because I love being
with you guys and I take you to go play
and I go well why
and he says
because when you're a parent
he says you have to split
the responsibility
and you have to with your mother and
father the mother the father can't just
be the disciplinarian and she used to
always put everything on him call him at
work
and she said
and when you have a child they
are the center of your attention they
become the center of the tension not you
and if you still want to be the center
of attention you cannot have children no
and I remember him saying this and it
all made sense because it was always
about my mother it was always about her
going out and always about her friends
and always about and less about us
it really I I I I don't think she was
capable I think she loved us but she did
not know how to be a mother and
that is to me
if you're ready to have a child you have
to be what you just said
your show has run its course it's now
their show and they're like Family
Matters they're gonna go on for [__]
ever you know that's yeah that's the
only way the child could be really
healthy and have a chance yeah and and
yet at the same time like there's a
balance to to be found like
your mom or a
I will say like a healthier balanced
version of of your situation where your
mom is like
whoa you know I I work my job love you
kids but you're tough like when I go out
with my girls one or two nights a week
like I come back refreshed I feel I feel
centered in myself they they see me like
that's that's a healthy thing you know
what I mean she gets to feel yeah it
still needs your time yeah yeah totally
so it's like there's a a version of of
that that I feel bad for her that she
couldn't sort of meet you halfway on
that yeah I hear what you're saying
you're saying like if you don't take
time for yourself if you don't exercise
or have moments for yourself or this
you'll go crazy you need that to be the
best mom you can sure that happens but
but yeah but the fact that from the
sound of things that your mom was like
why don't you just check back with me
when you're like a grown-up and we can
talk about grown-up stuffs okay like oh
yeah that's that's not that's not cool
yeah it's it's you know you always look
back and you're like you know you look I
remember always going to other people's
houses my friends parents
and it just felt like their parents
would listen to them and they would
engage with them and their friend it
just it was always just
going out going to my friend's house
staying there for a few days not no
one's allowed to come to our house no
one's allowed to spend the night it was
just like it was just a weird dynamic I
had a very weird dynamic and I think
that you know I've learned to forgive
I've learned to just say hey you guys
weren't good parents but that's because
you didn't know how to be good parents
and I forgive you and you know you gotta
let that [__] go you turned out good
though did I
I feel like from over here I'm working
on it I'm working I'm working on it I'm
still I mean we're it's a it's Evolution
man it's a work in progress
um you're still close to your parents
yeah they're both still alive
have you had to deal with loss
um I uh I mean yeah I'm a I'm a human
sure but
um yeah no I lost my grandparents like
that's the way you know it's supposed to
work what about what about you yeah I
mean sure I've had loss and it's like
you know but as we get older now or you
know you're getting up there I'm getting
up there a little bit we're still young
she looked at me like what here we go
here we go no but like you know the
older you get you know shit's gonna fall
apart oh yeah you know this has to
happen it's called life we know that
this and there's some friends I have
that I'm like oh my God as a mess as
I'll be it's not as close to some of
them who don't even want to talk about
it my friend Kristen who was on
Smallville Kristen crook told me to read
this book called The Future corpses or
your future corpses it's a story about
how to deal with death how to deal with
it she says it's amazing I have to read
it and prepare yourself and all this and
it's a good read damn but I think that
it's like
you know
um
can anything prepare you though I mean
okay I'll check out the book but you
know what I mean
I think that
I think that that's a big ask I think
that it's also unfair to your present
self yeah to ask that
of well to think about it all the time
you don't want to do that no sure but if
there's some way to prepare yourself to
say hey this makes me look at things in
a different light maybe this will help
me inevitably when this happens
yeah you know what I mean absolutely so
she's smart I feel like she whatever
she's doing I should be doing you she is
she's a reader I mean let's uh right are
you a reader
I feel like like the dumb joke I tell
sometimes is like I feel like I can tell
uh the last time I read a book by
roughly how old my oldest kid is look
no but um but yeah but but on loss like
I am I'm I'm completely terrified of it
and I'm just like super avoidant and
that was one of the hardest things about
being pregnant actually like the the
weirdest thing about it for me actually
was not like the physical changes it was
when you're part of the Inception of
something you get real in touch with
your mortality like real quick like the
moment I knew I was pregnant it was the
same moment I realized my parents were
gonna die you know it's very weird wow
it was just very sort of
messed up moment really yeah did you
have any postpartum or anything like
that no thank God thank God thank God
because that's serious that's a real
thing it's a big yeah and those hormones
stay in your body for like a year and
mess with you yeah I learned the hard
way because my one of my best friends
growing up his mom called me and said
hey Amy's gone and I go she left Nate
what and she's like no she she overdosed
on sleeping pills no she had postpartum
right after the baby was born and she
passed away and
you have to monitor if you see any
changes any depression anything you have
to be on top of it it's so it's such a
real thing and it's terrifying and it
was like I didn't really so I flew back
and I was on baby duty every two hours
changing diapers helping him out and
like having these deep conversations
with him and it was just it was intense
and it kind of made me realize like wow
I would another thing a freaking woman
has to go through you know what I mean
that no one really pays a lot of
attention to you don't hear a lot about
that do we talk about that a lot
I don't think we do I feel like every so
often someone comes forward and raises
their hands and and like talks about it
and and absolutely but oh my God yeah
terrible story terrible but let me ask
you this I have all the stuff you've
done you still enjoy acting you still
love the work I'm still worried about
Amy's family and her child no no
everything's everything's fine now she's
growing Alexa she's grown up to be a
beautiful girl talented volleyball
player she's happy with life Nate's a
great father he met a lovely woman I
went to their wedding it was awesome
he's there everybody's doing great but
it was just a tragic moment yeah so a
little happy ending that everybody's
doing really well uh look you've done so
many things right I mean you I know
we're getting I'm sorry we're just like
the Whiplash is just like I'm still up
bro okay but like
I noticed here that you did a video game
called Yakuza yes I was in that yeah
that was one of the lead voices so we
have so we have worked together and we
were also in Batman Beyond and I think
Return of the joker as voices but we
didn't know it no we did not I ha I
don't I've never have you played the
game
have you ever played it have you seen it
no no
um yeah have you ever seen your voice I
mean that that doesn't make sense have
you ever seen an animation with your
voice in it
um yeah yeah it's cool like Robot
Chicken it's easier than
um you know watching my my whole self
sometimes
do you give birth
I can watch myself I'm learning because
we're doing an also rewatch podcast with
Tom Welling who's next on Smallville so
we do a re-watch podcast where we have
and I never saw so many of them and
Ryan's on it and um
it's weird and it's hard and it's hard
for him looking at me and seeing this
character like it was so different than
I am and like it was a deep head shake
right oh man it's a different human
being it's bizarre it's bizarre man
because just because he's so together
he's so articulate he's so
powerful I don't know what is it I don't
whatever
just
rugged handsome just full
evil plans evil plans and just just real
do they still ask you to do Star Wars
stuff
um yeah I I uh for people who don't know
what you're talking about nobody well um
I've did some voices on Star Wars Old
Republic that that was just fun I I
literally began in a heartbeat yeah I
like it I like going to the booth and
you know oh my God every actor said this
in an interview but yeah like where you
get to just like go in and throw your
voice around and not care what you look
like and whatever
yeah because
um it's straight like but circling back
to your rewatch podcast like I I did a
re-watch podcast recently of um the show
Psych that I worked on exactly you did
the last season right
um
I love that they're they're the greatest
um I think I showed up in season like
three and four I honestly can't remember
which I feel bad about but it was a
great experience
um but one of the scenes I felt strange
saying it but when we were doing the
podcast I was like I I have no like I
understand that that's me and I'll
actually like I get it but I don't know
if we're on a stage I don't know if it
was a location like I don't isn't that
something how we don't remember but it's
it's scary I mean it's just I think you
just do jobs jobs and you a lot of times
you're like
yeah learn my lines gotta hit the mark
you're not thinking about being in the
moment a lot of times like where am I oh
look at this satin it's rare you just
kind of work yeah and sometimes when you
knock it out real quick or like you're
first up like by the time you sort of
wake up like the day is done it's almost
like did I drive home last night oh [__]
like if you're like was I acting like no
I didn't good
um yeah I get it yeah it's it's really
weird do you um
do you look back at like your 20s or 30s
or maybe just 20s let's say hour let's
just be shared and yeah let's just share
it or [__] you Ryan you're barely 30.
you're 34. you're all right listen
practically still growing yes you're
growing boy
do you ever how often do you reminisce
how often do you think of like oh man
those were the years do you think like
that do you think oh when you're a kid I
miss this and I missed so and so I
wonder what they're doing do you like
almost are you do you live in the past
at all or are you more of like that's
the rearview mirror I ripped it off I
live in today I don't ever ever look
back and if I do it's rare
think um
I'm I'm sentimental like I look back on
things sort of fondly like I'll remember
like oh we were friends when we did that
and sometimes you'll know that it's a
set friendship and not a life friendship
and you sometimes know that like in real
time yeah and that's totally okay and
I'm never someone who's like I don't
chase friendships or whatever but that's
the only thing that I think I feel
sentimental about is sometimes like the
people like oh we hadn't experience
together but what I really love about
again being in the game for a really
long time is that when you do get to
reconnect with people like we're doing
today is that like when you get to meet
someone when you're oh my God like 17 20
whatever and then again when you're in
your 40s like somewhere you get to meet
someone again you get to meet someone
twice in a lifetime you're like Hello
nice to meet this version like Freddie
Prince mm-hmm
I haven't asked it but I'd love him to
come on he is so candid and so funny I
feel like would he come on totally all
right I'll help you'll help me you know
he I'm sure you've met like by the way I
think we might have met years and years
ago it's funny I don't know he has some
of the best stories does he that yeah
yeah I'm not sure he would tell some of
them on record but I hope you guys get a
drink someday all right this is called
[__] talking with Rachel Lee Cook these
are my top tier patrons they get to ask
questions it's rapid fire okay
okay yeah patreon.com uh inside of you I
love you guys here you go Leanne loved
you in Psych and she's all that was what
was it like to work with Dooley Hill on
both projects okay first of all I saw
you thought my name was Leanne I'm not
good at I'm a rapid player right now
okay what was it like to work with dulay
Hill I love dulay he is hilarious he
taught me an active trick that I will
never forget which is if you're in a
scene with a lot of people get yourself
into a corner of the room near nobody
else so that when everybody does their
coverage you don't have to be in it
that's like an acting tip that I picked
up it's so brilliant and it works yeah
and he also goes if there's if there
happens to be a kid in the scene kid has
to go home kid Works Limited hours go
stand by the kid
they'll shoot you you're close up you
get to go home
I'm making dolay sound lazy no these are
tricks of the trade he has spent more
hours on set than probably that almost
anyone I know so wow you just gotta do
what you got Kelly s was there a
particular fad or Trend in the 90s that
you look back on and cringe
do you wear shoulder pads
I feel great about shoulder pads okay
good okay um no but uh the the thing
that I looked back on from the 90s I'm
like no is I completely took my eyebrows
off it was a bad it was a bad look you
you what my eyebrows were like gone
I blame Drew Barrymore
directly little Lisa how did you get the
role of voicing Tifa Lockhart in the
Final Fantasy franchise I auditioned for
it and they um they played the Japanese
version for me and they were just like
can you do something with this with this
Essence and I tried and then
yeah 10 years with the with the job was
10 years yeah yeah they rotated the cast
pretty recently but it was a great time
good for you thank you Sophie M can you
tell us about the audition process for
the babysitters club did you audition
for other parts in that movie also
very smart question I'm impressed that
people know that and yeah I think all of
us sort of auditioned for different
roles Sophie M
um I auditioned for Marianne and Christy
we talked about how you love the
babysitter's clothes yeah
[Applause]
uh yeah and I did not find out if I got
the part of Marianne for a very long
time because they were looking to cast
the role of Christy who's a more Central
character to the to the piece
gotcha so the audition process was
um I just I walked into a room did my
best I guess it worked out maybe no one
else auditioned because I am not great
in that movie I every honestly
I was terrible 27 years ago don't
understand the stakes of Any Given scene
like it is it's it's pretty uneven
performance I gotta look back and just
smile
by the way I was supposed to do a movie
with you I was supposed to do this movie
Red Sky I was supposed to get a rush to
the guy Dave Riggs or whatever took me
up in a MIG and we flew and felt the
g-force and I ended up saying no last
minute
do you know if he's dead now
how did he die
flying someone around in one of those
planes and he took the director's
assistant with him who's a young woman
she was only 23. when was that
when did he die I think it was around
2013.
and I have like like right after the no
the movie was 2007 or something right
yeah so it was after that by a couple
years
um oh my God I flew with him he was also
a career Criminal Who spent a lot of
time in sing-sing who didn't have a
pilot's license when he was flying you
because he buzzed people as a publicity
stunt in his plane on the Santa Monica
Pier who still had Burns and were in the
hospital like when we were shooting the
movie this is all true oh you can you
can look it up
I flew with that guy he didn't even have
a pilot's license not an active one
it was literally revoked I could have
died that day 100
holy [__] the other actors fly with him
too
I don't remember to be honest with you
it was his contribution to the movie
that he was going to be flying these you
know retired Russian Megs that was like
and he did fly them yeah
there was no accidents God
I wasn't there for that person you
aren't there for that part you were the
love interest yeah
was it fun shooting in Russia no you
didn't have any fun you cannot talk to
you about the movie really it was it was
um
here's what I will say it came out and I
haven't even seen I've only seen the
trailer but it seems like it came out
way better than it had any right to but
it wasn't fun it wasn't fun for you it
was
um
it was dangerous and completely insane
it was the most Lawless production I've
ever been on oh my gosh and nobody could
kind of like save us because we were in
Russia you have to get like a work
permit to even like get into the country
like there's no there's no Union can
touch you out there like it's it was it
was really wild yeah Jesus I will tell
you some stories that will like blow
your hair back later yeah please oh my
god look this has been amazing what's
going on next what do you do now
um I'm gonna in the spring I have a
Netflix movie coming out what is it it's
called a tourist's guide to love I've
transitioned
um very much into creating my own sort
of stuff so yeah you're executive
producer you produced a Hallmark movie
that was yes I've been making movies
with Hallmark who've been incredible
creative Partners to me but yeah this is
my second movie uh with Netflix
um and yeah I just I'm a sucker for a
good romantic comedy I love that I say
so yeah it's a travel romance called a
tourist's Guide to Love and we shot in
Vietnam for two months and that wasn't
incredible experience and it's an
absolutely gorgeous looking movie so I'm
gonna look me up for a role for
something
you can play the Vietnamese guy
that's frowned these days you have range
I'm sorry and by the way I'll call you
next time
you're so close with your brother and
he's like he's doing the new Blade
Runner Series yeah
I see you posting about him I love that
you're so close oh my gosh I Ben yes I
love Ben so that the ends of the Earth
he's such a good kid and he's a grown-up
and it's I still can't believe it I'm so
proud of him oh this has been a treat oh
my gosh I feel like I'm taking up so
much of your time not at all I'll let
you have your day Michael this was
awesome wasn't it you're so easy to talk
to I've been looking forward to this I
had all these things and I never even I
just talked what's on the things will
you show me no I mean there's nothing we
talked about it I somehow memorized it I
looked at it this morning and I was just
like you know oh my God look at this I
think we discussed everything we need to
discuss perfect this is great you had
fun yeah I had so much fun thank you so
much
you're home Ryan yeah yes I feel like
there's a question mark at the end of it
yeah all right thanks wow
what can I say
I enjoyed it I really enjoy her I uh
she's so nice she looks I mean so good
yeah I mean I would never think she was
even remotely close to 40 years old she
really takes care of herself
you know I probably look like her you
know
but you don't look 50 either well 48
whatever you look probably 33.
how old are you 34.
well with a beard yeah when you when you
shave you're like you're you're 28 and
that's true well anyway that's true um
anyway thanks for listening guys I hope
you enjoyed it
um please listen continue to listen and
support the podcast
um we've been around for years this is
our our first rodeo
um we're not a podcast it's just we're
not not a celebrity here that's trying
to just make some extra money I mean you
want to make money I guess but you know
what I'm saying like this is this is
we've been doing we have over 250 guests
we've been doing this we figure
ourselves out we know what we're doing
here we're helping we're helping each
other you've been around we've been
around yeah here are the shout outs the
patreon go to patreon.com inside of you
and these are the lovable folks that get
back to the podcast and without them I
couldn't do it
would accent
what accent what didn't we do last time
French Canadian
and then CD yes
salavi little Lisa Yukiko
um
Brian H
nah Looney Tunes
Oh Canada I don't know I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know what that was
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Kristen K Raj C Joshua D Jennifer and
Stacy El Jamal f g l b Mike Eldon
Supremo 99 more Santiago am Chad w-e-n-p
Janine R Maya P Maddie s Belinda and
Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T
by the way I'm going to um
Telford to Wales for a con really yeah
I've never been to Wales
well well whales whales do you want
where's where's I'd say go with me but
it's going to be a kind of a quick
turnaround that's right where's the
whales I would love to go to Wales but
when is it
um it's in May hmm to me but it'd be
like a Thursday and come back Sunday or
Monday morning why is it so quick
because you know you lose a day when you
get there then you do the con you come
home there's no reason just kind of you
know I'm traveling too much to stick
around it's a whirlwind man Liliana a
Talia M Tom and Betsy D chat L Dan and
big Stevie W Angel and C Cory K
defnexton Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Camille ask Joni B Joni M you
Megan T Angela f Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Eric H Shane RMR
Andrew M zuruichi 77 Andreas and Oracle
Karina and Amanda R gen B Kevin e
Stephanie K jorel Bill yes jam and J
Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone H
Miss s Brian L kdb Aaron R Kendall L
house J Meredith I Charlene C and Kara C
uh I love all of you thank you for
listening thank you for supporting the
podcast
I want to actually spend like a couple
of days where I'm not working where I
could just really go and respond to
everybody it's so hard because you're
doing two shows and you're traveling and
doing all these things and I just want
people to know much I appreciate them so
I feel like I I wanted to respond to you
and sometimes I don't it doesn't mean I
don't love you and um
but thank you thank you for listening to
the podcast today and hopefully you'll
continue listening some great guests
coming up and I'm really working hard to
get as many guests as I can that you
like and talk about mental health talk
about real [__] so thank you from the
Hollywood Hills and Hollywood California
I am Mike Rosenbaum hi Brad
a little way to the camera we love you
guys and as always seriously uh be good
to yourselves be good to yourselves all
right we'll see
[Music]